I changed the way I shop for my
groceries and where I shop for my
groceries and where I put gas in my car
it's a better question yeah and I I
think that's the part that hurts
everybody everybody feels it almost
almost regardless of what economic you
know uh status you're
in you can hear the pain of so many
Americans right now because biomics
isn't just hurting your wallets right
now it's having a major impact on your
future and your children children's
future too 401K balances are shrinking
and according to Fidelity Investments
it's due to an uptick and hardship
withdrawals joining me now is Republican
strategist Garrett ventry G Garrett
great to see you uh is bomic working for
anyone Lisa thanks for having me the
short answer is Biden nomics is not
working the entire messaging strategy
from the Biden White House and President
Biden's campaign has been to Gaslight
the American people and tell him that
the economy is going well inflation
isn't a big deal and their financial
Situation's great the problem with that
is again it's like a used car salesman
who's extremely Shady trying to convince
you know a 90-year-old woman that a
Buick La saber uh is the same thing as a
brand new Ferrari it's just not working
and people simply are not buying it if
you look at the data real quick here
just on the economy you're talking about
Thanksgiving dinner in 2023 cost double
than it did in 2019 mortgage rates are
triple than they were when President
Biden took office inflation is higher
than When Donald Trump was in office
four years ago uh everything's higher
gas groceries and people are feeling the
pain across the board here if you look
at the polling it shows quickly here uh
your Fox News poll how people feel about
these issues and 78% of Voters say that
inflation is bad and the economy is bad
here and that's not just Republicans 77%
of Independents say that and eye popping
number 46% of Democrats feel that as
well also in that same poll 2third of
Americans are saying we don't think it's
going to get better here soon and that
undermines the entire argument of Joe
Biden when they've looked at these polls
a year out they say well listen I know
Donald Trump is beating President Biden
in five or six states uh he is beating
him nationally in almost every poll
that's come out here but they say listen
a year from now it'll be different but
two3 again are saying it's not it's
going to get worse they're also
concerned about his age that's not going
to get better any a year so again4 Jo
bid big problems gett I wanted to get
you on this I I do worry a little bit
though you know Democrats are trying to
get abortion on the ballot particularly
in swing States for 2024 we've seen the
strategy work for them in past
particularly the the last midterm
elections so what can Republicans do
about that what should they do about
that well I think real quick here you've
seen president Trump do this saying it
should be up to the states in Arizona
you've seen Carrie Lake a Senate
candidate there too saying you know
Republicans shouldn't you know we've
invested in boing out corporations Bing
out Banks we should be invested in
Saving babies and helping women there
and I think that's a strong message that
we should focus on here and pivot back
to the economy where again more voters
are feeling the pain from Joe Biden we
have a strong message to be able to run
in 2024 to fix things Garrett thanks
appreciate your time hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else